hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well towards the end
of his discussion of ethics in Chapter
six of language truth and logic a jair
is going to make yet another rather
startling claim namely that ethics as a
discipline is really just sort of a
sub-discipline of the social sciences
and by the social sciences he has in
mind in his own time sociology and
psychology which kind of complement each
other
you know psychology tends to be focused
on the individual although of course
there's group psychology and we can go
on with that sociology tends to be
focused on society and groups and both
of them are viewed by somebody like air
as if there are purely empirical
sciences what makes them a science is
that they observe the you know in the
case of psychology the feelings the you
know correlated thoughts the experiences
of persons and then try to come up with
some sort of hypotheses about them that
can be empirically verified or falsified
sociology does something similar but for
groups they they're also you know in the
time that he's writing quite given to
use
mathematical models to analyze things to
to tabulate data which still goes on a
lot today we could probably also place
into this category of the social
sciences things like economics
anthropology at least to some degree
depending on you know which
anthropological approach or theory we're
talking about political science insofar
as political science is less theory and
more application which looks a lot like
sociology criminology of course which
spins out of sociology you know all of
these these areas that are applying a
sort of scientific viewpoint on human
beings to study their behavior and so
not just their behavior but also beliefs
values customs changes over time what
wouldn't fit in there would be say
history or the arts or anything like
that the humanities so Ayer says towards
the end of this section ethical
philosophy consists in saying that
ethical precepts or ethical concepts
rather are pseudo concepts that is false
concepts not really concepts more
nonsense than actually even false and
therefore unanalyzed well they're
they're intractable to philosophy so we
can't really have any meaningful ways of
resolving moral disagreements they're
really just based on our emotions or our
moral sensibilities as he says which
which is really a factor of the moral
education or conditioning which we have
received so he says because of this that
there is no such thing as ethical
science as an elaboration of a true
system of moral so we don't mean that
there's no such thing as ethical
as and you can't do science ethically
although you know maybe you can't
according to err either or ethical just
means like in accordance with what the
institutional review board
okay's or something along those lines if
we analyze what the statement means it
means that ethics itself cannot be
scientific it cannot be something that
is known in such a way as to provide
objectivity and clarity and the way that
the science is typically do so he says
that the further task of describing the
different feelings that the different
ethical terms are used to express and
the different reactions that they
customarily provoke that is a task and
here he singles out the psychologist but
we could think of the social scientist
in general he says as ethical judgments
are mere expressions of feeling there is
no way to determine the validity of any
ethical system and in fact no sense
asking whether any such system is true
all we can actually do and this is where
the social sciences come in all we can
actually do is he says is to ask what
are the moral habits of a given person
or group of people and what causes them
to have precisely those habits and
feelings he says this falls wholly
within the scope of the existing social
sciences so notice what he's saying
there's a descriptive side to it what
are the actual mores or habits of
Association of passions feelings drives
what goes on within a given person or a
given group or a society and what
produced those now the what produced
those is a little bit of a different
inquiry isn't it it's one thing to
describe and say well from everything
that we can tell having done some
polling it appears that you know
everybody here is in favor of drinking
water and the people over there
less in favor of drinking water on one
to five Likert scale
you know those those very much in
agreement very much in disagreement
right those things that you do in
surveys the people over here had a four
point nine average for drinking water
the people over here had only a three
point six which means they're very
ambivalent about it okay so that's
descriptive we could say similar things
with stealing the people over here are
ambivalent about whether stealing is
wrong whereas the people over here think
it's definitely wrong figuring out where
those beliefs came from is a bit of a
different type of inquiry and air is
kind of glossing over this very quickly
although he's going to give us some
interesting examples that show us what
this might look like in just a bit
but the point is the things that we
traditionally associate with ethics then
would fall within the scope of the
social sciences and the social science
is done in a very interesting way where
they cannot engage in any sort of
moralizing on their own part now you
should ask yourself does this really
look like the social sciences of even
airs time let alone our own time is
there something like a complete
agreement among psychologists
sociologists even economists about
exactly what you know the theory is to
use to understand things and the answer
is no as a matter of fact the social
sciences are a hodgepodge of many
different approaches but they do offer
some some possibilities what about other
things he says ethics is just a branch
nothing but more than a department of
psychology and sociology and they says
well what about causes stream this comes
from the word Casas in Latin right and
it means looking at particular instances
or cases and and typically the word
cross the street was used in a bad sense
to mean like you know trying to get
yourself out of the rigorousness of
moral systems so you'd like inquire into
the
particular cases oh there's a lot of
exceptions here air doesn't actually
mean something quite like that in this
case he says in case anyone thinks we're
overlooking the existence of casuistry
we can remark that Kansas tree is not a
science now notice what he does say it
is a purely analytical investigation of
the structure of a given moral system in
other words he says it's an exercise in
formal logic so you have a system laid
out and then you analyze that and you
say well that's what the the system
actually does consist in so he gives
some interesting examples here of how
this sort of psychological inquiry might
actually work and you notice that the
examples that he picks and the way that
he frames it is not really something
particularly new these explanations go
all the way back into the 19th century
and perhaps even before that but he's
providing some some examples of what
might tell us why people have the moral
systems or beliefs or commitments that
it does so he says we would like to
account for the konchem and hedonistic
theories of morals and then he says well
if we investigate it what did we
discover now we should actually think
about this are these by air zone
methodology really all that verifiable
or is he you know kind of spinning out a
hypothesis here so he says that fear of
God's displeasure both conscious and
unconscious and fear of the enmity the
hatred of society are the sources of
much of he says them one of the chief
causes of moral behavior right so he's
actually skipping over beliefs and he's
talking about moral behavior why do
people behave morally because either
consciously or unconsciously that is
without even registering it they're
afraid of God maybe there's no God of
course that's just a figment of their
imagination or they're afraid of society
and society does exist
right other people so he says that these
sorts of fears are in fact why through
too many people moral precepts present
themselves as categorical commands and
then he says as one finds also the moral
code of a society is partly determined
by the beliefs of that society
concerning the conditions of its own
happiness or in other words that a
society encourages or discourages given
conduct by the use of moral sanctions
based on what it does to society as a
whole
thereby promoting altruism and
suppressing egoism we wind up with
hedonistic or you die monistic ethics so
because society presses itself upon us
and says you know this sort of behavior
is conducive to the the goodness the you
know whatever's good for society in
prospering more people living you know
not not having traffic snarls it's
something like that whatever whatever it
happens to be providing us with more
M&Ms if that's really what we're into
having more chocolate whatever it
happens to be the connection between
morality and happiness here is what
gives us hedonistic or you die monastic
ethics and on the other hand we have the
sort of conscient at Agora chol de
ontological ethics he says here we go
just as the moral theory of conscience
based on the fact that moral precepts
have for some people the force of
inexorable commands and they says as
each of these theories ignores the fact
that lies at the root of the other both
can be criticised as one-sided but this
is not the main objection they're
essential defect is that they treat
propositions which refer to the causes
and attributes of our ethical feelings
as if they were definitions of ethical
concepts so error has to get in one more
time saying listen
neither the diamond istic or hedonistic
ethics nor conscient ethics are really
grasping what ethics is about which is
basically just feeling
feelings sentiments and our expressions
of them and attempts to get other people
to see things the same way as us so
psychology if this is indeed psychology
allows us a window into understanding
how these moral systems arise and we
could have similar things for like you
know how did the idea of natural law
come in or you know for thinking about
Confucius death exsist other cultures
influenced by the Chinese Chinese
culture right and we could go on and on
and on but the basic point is we can do
some sort of analysis some sort of
reconstruction after the fact to explain
where these these ethical concepts and
commitments come from but they're
ultimately just pseudo concepts when we
get down to the level of analysis except
insofar as the social sciences handle
them and then tell ethics here's what
we've got
so ethics for air ultimately becomes a
sort of subdivision or sub-discipline of
the social sciences and doesn't have any
genuine scope of its own
you